spruce thanks for joining us tell me
what's up with LSU at Florida is it
postponed or is it canceled well
technically it's postponed and the right
referent the time being it feels like it
may be canceled right now I think the
biggest issue here and obviously safety
is it a premium when it came to this
hurricane but what the SEC and certainly
Florida's ad Jeremy Foley did was
essentially you know played this thing
out and let it get to the point where it
was either play it and you know it was
either going to be in gainesville or not
at all and whatever the contingencies
were they just let this thing drag on
and on too long where they had no other
options this weekend and so if you look
back a few you know ten years ago when
it was Hurricane Rita was right on the
heels of Katrina Mike Slive stepped in
the SEC Commissioner the taimen and
moved the LSU tennessee game which was a
homecoming into a Monday night and
switched it in this case Greg Sankey let
these let the 80s kind of point fingers
and it turned out to be a big mess and I
ultimately talking to people within the
SEC footprint they're like you know what
this wouldn't have happened if if if
Mike's I would still run the show but
Greg Sankey the new commissioner just
really got himself behind the eight ball
okay but is this a situation with
neither team wanting to have a loss
granted Florida's losing home revenue
but also if they have one less game that
means one less loss for these two
schools does that matter at all well I
think this matters is a bigger issue
than just florida and LSU because it
affects both division races Tennessee
which is already beaten Florida could
end up if they have you know played one
more game in Florida doesn't have that
loss the head-to-head becomes a muta
moot point and so Florida would go to
the SEC title game hypothetically again
this is a big if but in LSU wins out and
would have beat alabama who has to go to
Baton Rouge this year even if
beaten Alabama that head-to-head could
cost them the you know the fact that it
would be just you know and non-existent
so not only does this affect these two
schools but it really has over affects
the whole the whole sport of college
football because of the SEC and because
of what it means to both divisional
title races what if Texas beats Oklahoma
I think you'll hear a lot of the Charlie
Strong is getting fired talk will be put
on the back burner for a while I really
do just as it relates to that story and
I had talked to some folks inside the
Texas program over the weekend and they
said you know really if he could have
gotten a team to seven and five I would
have been too when improvement from last
year they know the team is really young
felt they felt like Charlie Strong would
have been safe and he was on the right
track now all those people feel like he
needs to win nine game as opposed to
seven and I said what changed and the
answer was unless you changed LSU job
came open they fired Les Miles Tom
Herman's Tom Herman's window of where he
would be it would have changed in a lot
of people's minds down there Tom murmurs
a former Texas graduate assistant so
it's gotten very messy down there for
Charlie Strong and the pressure is very
real he's obviously II he demoted his
defensive coordinator has taken over the
play calling himself so you know the
pressure is real it's only year three
though and I'll say this whoever is
coaching Texas in 2017 was going to get
a loaded team because that it's a very
young team they were probably a year
away from being top 15 top ten caliber
we just had Tom Herman on last out of
the Houston head coach why do we assume
that he will leave Houston dan I I mean
I I think Houston's become a very good
job and I I know Tom really likes it
there but if anybody thinks that a coach
is going to stay at Houston which in all
likely is not going to get into the big
12 at the expense of Texas which is
arguably the best job with the best
resources in college football which by
the way now look at what how the big 12
shakes up Oklahoma seems to be kind of
struggling to struggling to move forward
Baylor who had that emerged as a power
is going through a scandal it's hard to
expect that Baylor's not going to take a
back step Texas is built very well going
the way Charlie Strong would have if he
doesn't get this turned around and
getting another year Charlie Strong at
the very least has left the program
better than he found it I just have a
hard time believing that that that Tom
Herman go you know what I'm staying at
Houston with lesser facilities with a
lesser footprint with a lesser
opportunity as a non power 5 school I
mean it's not like we're saying is this
tech is this Houston vs texas tech or
this Houston versus even TCU this is
Houston vs Texas we're talking about I
mean the idea that Tom Berman would turn
down that to stay at Houston just
doesn't seem to make much sense if
you're being realized yeah but Houston's
closer to a national title in Texas is
this year I mean if Tom Herman was
coaching coach in Texas and Nyjah Huston
it might be a different situation I mean
look at all the factors that Houston
needs to have fall in line for them just
to have a hope of getting in the playoff
they need to they need to run the table
there is no margin for error and then
they need help I mean look I think tech
I think using deserves to be in the
playoffs consideration certainly if they
beat you no way what would be a pen into
Louisville team at the at the end of the
year at home but they are going to need
somebody from the pac-12 to lose out to
be Washington they're going to need help
either from Washington losing or either
a combination of the Big Ten or sec
stumbling along the way and then you
know all the things have to line up it's
not that way when you're the powerhouse
program in a power 5 school you just
don't your margin for error is just not
as Slam at that point good stuff Bruce
enjoy the weekend always great to talk
to you thanks for joining us my pleasure
thank you Dan that's Bruce Feldman fox
sports college football insider the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
you